um this team is the second best team in
california
[Music]
all right dwyane wade welcome into just
playing one thing i have learned about
athletes is you all want to win whether
it's in your actual sport
or if it's game night whatever the case
may be you gotta do what you can
to get that w we're gonna play heads up
which i'm gonna show something on my
phone
you get me to guess the word our first
category we're gonna do basketball this
is the football caligori
yes exactly but the next one will be a
little harder but we'll warm you up with
some basketball
yeah this thing will go good ready set
and i'll close my eyes so i cannot see
oh when the bag goes to the sideline
and the restaurant not inbound
there you go yup uh he's missed the
triple-double
runs of westbrook
um this team right here um
is in the city that i live uh what i
live in california this team is the
second best team in california los
angeles clippers
yeah there you go
uh he's one of the greatest college
coaches ever i wouldn't
no okay here you go
yup uh this is something that i
uh my last year the nba i came off of
the
um with the miami heat i came off the
what
i'm on the bench
okay give yourself some credit those
were good clues we got one two three
four
five six we got six look at that
and you have switched seats in so many
ways right like you went from
player to kind of media hosting role
what is one perspective that you had on
the media when you were playing
that is not a perspective that you have
on the media now
well that they was haters
yeah gimbal is that right you look at
guys who
first of all we're we in studio right
looking at tnt and i talked about this
from an interview recently with charles
barker which who i love
but you know if he's in the studio i
never see him at the arenas i never see
him at practice
um and he's away from the game for 10 15
20 years and the game is different and
if he's talking about
uh you know the players today we talk
about the game today he's talking about
certain things you're doing and it's
coming off and you hear it if you're one
of those teams that's on tv
every week you hear it every week so
you're like yo why you keep coming at me
yeah
i think you think they're haters but
then once you get on this side you
understand that everything is just
opinion based
uh something is motivational based i
think shaq gets a a rap because he comes
at guys
and you know guys should come back but a
lot of it for shaq in his mind this is
for me to motivate you
so you start getting into the minds of
of people that's at the desk and what
they have to do
to you know to talk about the game to
build ratings to stay up
long nights you know in the morning you
know all these things
if you had to play in a game right now
could you still
do you still make some shape right now
right now this exact moment nothing no
nothing you're it you're out all right
someone actually because they were like
yo if you can can you get ready for the
playoffs as a team need you
i said absolutely no like
don't discredit what it takes to be a
professional athlete yeah
you know i mean it should be good my
body will break all the way down
come on give me a easy one start off
y'all don't be playing okay
one of the biggest shows ever was two
women not i love lucy
not all of those girls
[Music]
it goes from cars to something that goes
to like um
transformers i think there's a doctor
show
uh california grey's anatomy general
hospital
d.o.c is that is that cali i don't know
it's cali but it's a it's not about
doctors
people add all the things they do to
like their instagram bio yours could say
okay mba on tnt
tuesday part of the utah jazz ownership
group wade sellers now you have this
huge new project hosting
the cube on tbs which premieres um on a
june 10th
so tell me what exactly is
the cube well the cube is exactly what
it sounds like it's a cube
you know in this game we have roughly
what 62 different
uh variations of games that you can play
and you don't know which ones
will come up but what makes the game
cool for me
is you get nine lives to weigh 250 000
you know so that's a lot of bread and
correct me if i'm wrong but if there's
something that they can't do
they are allowed to pull you in for one
shot
yeah yeah so we gave the contestants two
assists as well so they get nine lives
but they also can call on the cube to
kind of simplify one of the games
they get in a tough situation and also
they can call on me to come in
and play one game but it has to be a one
player game and i can come in and i
i get one chance to try to win this
money for them if you were in the cube
and you could call on one current nba
player who has to make one shot for you
who do you call okay curry easy
our producers made a custom pack called
wade's world they did a deep dive
on your instagram got a bunch of little
tidbits about you so this pack your
waves world pack is
all about you so you got to get them
right i got this
oh this is the uh water mobile that you
lebron
your wife and yes
oh oh my gosh the best poultry in
chicago mild sauce
uh harold's chicken yep
[Music]
uh okay i don't know what this is but
okay blank
rivers the basketball player right now
blank rivers
also rivers okay and then and austin
and uh oakland alley yes yes
uh okay this is an old show like a whole
bunch of like people at a bar
uh cheers yes oh
wrapper ice oh your show duh
you like you yeah no no yes cube yeah
um oh this is a wine a red wine
uh d-way cellars no no no a specific
wine
what's another word for taxi
cab cab yeah cabernet
hey hey we did pretty good wait what is
austin and
ally it was a show that was on
uh it's like a kid show and i was off
okay i'm like oh my god i do not know
how to get him to say ally but
no that was good you got to give me like
a ready
there we go good job we are going to
move on to the
rapid fire segment fill in the blink
dwayne wade is
nice first pair of sneakers
uh elise okay last meal
burger childhood crush gabriel
oh me and birds we really
i'm trying to get better but birds and i
just we really don't vibe too much
okay birds i remember that uh biggest
l biggest l um
life is and i say l is it i don't take
it as long as i take it as lessons
so the lesson so life is a lesson and
that's the biggest ill you can get
i like that okay advice to your rookie
self
advice to my rookie self um try to be
um try to be able to look in the future
and understand that the game is gonna go
to three pointers and so start shooting
them very early so you
have a long career
hey and that's that's life advice
everybody look to the future
work on your three-point shot whatever
that shot may be
work on it oh well that was amazing
thank you so much for joining dee
and everybody make sure you watch the
cube on june 10th
on tbs thank you